قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
دفاعاتها تمكنت من اسقاط 13 مسيره من نوع
شاهد في مقاطعه
في مقاطعه قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها
استعاده السيطره على منطقه حيث دارت معارك
ضاريا في وحول روجين واستارومايويورك على
بعد نحو 60 ميلا الى الجنوب الغربي من
المقاطعه الخاضعه للسيطره الروسيه وقال
المتحدث باسم قوه الدفاع الاوكرانيه
الجنوبيه
ان روسيا تستهدف البنيه التحتيه للموانئ
الاوكرانيه في اوديسا جنوبيه البلاد وقالت
قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
النادفاعاتها صدت هجوما روسيا على منطقه
خاركاز بينما لا تزال تصد هجمات روسيه
استهدفت ليمان ومارينكا وافديفيكا بمقاطعه
من جانبها قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
انظمه دفاعها الجوي دمرت الثلاثه طائره
مسيره اوكرانيه فوق مقاطعه كالوجا جنوب
غرب موسكو